now if you're not familiar with jeff
allen i want to fix that right away he
is a consultant for national business
administration focusing on agile
waterfall and hybrid project management
he has 35 more than 35 years of
experience as a trainer and a presenter
and a content developer he's conducted
more than 250 training sessions for
project management exam prep for over
five thousand participants
and he's held a lot of uh various roles
in his career from vice president of
business development at hp the executive
director of the california commission on
the u.s bicentennial and on and on a
tremendously qualified gentleman we have
here with us today and we're lucky to
have him
before we get rolling though i want to
make sure that everybody is
seeing the right dashboard and familiar
with how to use it and knows what to
expect so
first of all i just want to make sure
i'm not speaking into the darkness as go
to webinar can sometimes do to us so go
ahead and find the questions module on
your dashboard if you would and just
type in a quick uh hello there let me
know where you're joining us from and
tell me what uh what the weather is like
there for you right now that might be a
fun way to get us started
just go ahead and type into the
questions module and
and we'll uh see who's with us today
that questions module
is uh your best friend during this
presentation oh i see lots of folks
letting us know where they are fantastic
and what a great variety too sunny in
the cayman islands oh my gosh i'm
jealous
cloudy in new jersey pennsylvania is a
beautiful sunny fall day i can imagine
the colors are starting to turn there
we see south africa cameroon tampa
india
uh florida again partly cloudy with a
chance of meatballs is that what i'm
saying no a chance of showers all right
when you leave work
and uh cloudy in bangalore mexico's
paris i love this i love that we have
people from so many different places
joining us it's fantastic the world
truly is a very small place and i'm so
happy to be sharing this with everybody
uh
let's see sunny to sunny if you ask me
yes
all right so thank you for letting me
know where you are uh that questions
module is your best friend as jeff is
doing his presentation which is going to
run on the order of 30 to 45 minutes if
you have questions go ahead and type
them into this question module we will
gather them all together and we will
loop back around at the end of the
presentation and do a proper q a
from end to end
and we'll get to as many of your
questions as we possibly can if you hear
something super brilliant super wise
super insightful
you want to share it with your friends
on social please by all means do so you
can go ahead and live tweet as we're
going you can share on facebook or
linkedin or wherever you like
if you want to use the hashtag sl
webinars that's okay too uh that's
probably everything you ever wanted to
hear from me we know how your dashboard
works we know you can hear us
uh we know where you're joining us from
so i'm going to get out of your way and
turn things over to mr jeff allen jeff
i'm so happy to have you here today
thanks for joining us
i'm going to uh get out of your way put
myself on mute and let you take over sir
well welcome thank you hey chip did you
say somebody is joining us from the
cayman islands i did yes
you know we have snow on the mountains
already here i have a proposal
i say let's shut down this webinar let's
all go to the cayman islands and do this
in person
i'm right there with you my friend if i
could make that work we could get a
teleporter built into this go to webinar
thing i'd be right there with you
but since we can't do that we will forge
ahead with what we've got planned
um thank you for that uh nice
introduction chip welcome everybody
i
am grateful for this opportunity to
spend a little time with you all
i love it when project managers get
serious about
their profession and about acquiring
their skills and
tools and techniques that they're going
to need to be successful
um you know what i find is that when
people get serious about project
management they actually just become
better people because so many of the
tools and techniques that you learn
have such broad application to your life
um what i'd like to do to just sort of
make sure that we're all on the same
page is just chat a little bit about
project management
and i'm going to blast through a couple
of little slides here
and
get us to where i want to be
there's our login screen you've probably
already done this we'll chat a little
bit more about
simply learn
you know what we do here at simplylearn
is we help people get ahead by helping
them get certified
and when it comes to project management
we're experts at this and project
management to me
is simply the science of getting stuff
done and everybody has to get stuff done
and when you think about projects
for example the pyramids in egypt the
roman aqueducts cathedrals in europe the
first
railway in america
nice hotels in the cayman islands
all of these are examples of projects
and project management as a profession
was really practiced you know
historically informally and it wasn't
until about the 1950s that it began to
emerge as a distinct profession
and
tools like gantt charts and some other
informal techniques and tools were used
but that's about where we would mark the
beginning of the modern project
management era
and when it comes to defining what a
project is and i expect for some of you
this is kind of a review
it's a temporary endeavor that results
in something unique
meaning projects will have a beginning
and an end
now products that result from projects
can spawn many other projects you know
like maintenance projects and
other improvement projects related to
the product but the project itself has a
beginning and an end and so
they're very easy to manage you know
when you you know what you're going to
do on the front end you know when you're
finished at the end
um and so that lends itself to
having best practices that can be tested
and measured as we go forward
projects are not
routine day-to-day operations those are
different
we can run projects that might impact
operations but the day-to-day routine
stuff are not projects
so
whether you're doing um software
development or building a building
expanding sales into a new market or
maybe even doing a research effort those
are all examples of projects
now when it comes to how we manage a
project
there are really two approaches to
project management there's waterfall and
there's agile
at a very high level the differences are
these
the traditional waterfall approach is a
plan driven approach which favors clear
requirements on the front end the
creation of a master plan up front
and then measuring your actual results
against the plan as the project
progresses
and then the agile approach is for
projects that are more unclear and
uncertain
and focus on delivering value to the
customer in frequent short iterations
now when you're thinking about
promoting a project
and doing it successfully
you need to have some versatility to
know which way you want to go should you
do it in the more traditional approach
or should you do it in the more agile
approach
and project managers today and in the
future are not going to have the luxury
of really specializing in just waterfall
or just agile
in this chart right here you can sort of
see how you could determine whether the
agile approach would be a better fit as
opposed to the waterfall approach
and you can see that in kind of the
light orange boxes the ones that are
labeled simple and complicated that's
the sweet spot for waterfall
that's where your requirements are
either known or they're easily knowable
the
requirements might be complicated but
they're still
um discoverable easily
and then when you get into the green
area that's
agile which we label as complex and
that's where at the beginning of the
project we don't know everything about
it it's going to have to be discovered
now it's still reasonably predictable
but yet there's that level of
uncertainty that doesn't exist in
projects that are better served by the
waterfall approach
there is up there at the top right
uh chaos and uh you know if you ever
find yourself with the project that's in
that area
let someone else run it um that's where
your requirements aren't knowable and
it's not predictable and those really
aren't candidates for you know formal
project management
now you know years ago i
i got hired by a buddy of mine actually
a friend he called me and said hey i'm
uh working at compact computer
and we need somebody to run a project
for us it's a project that's joint with
microsoft and we're going to be doing
seminars all across
the united states
and it was a perfect time for me perfect
fit and i said i'm on board
i ended up running this project for
about three years and what's interesting
is during the course of that project the
friend that hired me
actually got ripped
right reduction in force he got laid off
and
when i was finished with the project
i ended up discovering formal project
management in the sense of getting
credentials
i did you know i didn't know that much
about credentials and you know and i'm
one of these guys that i don't like
taking tests either i think they're
stupid generally i don't think they're
good measures of how well you're going
to do in the marketplace
um but
it seemed like at the end of that
that effort that maybe i had to look
into it and so
i ended up getting my pmp certification
and it was a whole new world for me
and it opened up doors that i didn't
realize certifications would open
so at simply learn when we say you know
get ahead get certified that's exactly
what happens now this same friend of
mine
a couple of years later called me up and
he says jeff i hear you're actually
doing project management training you're
doing pnp exam prep classes and i said i
am
and he says you know what he said
i'm working for
um
shoot i can't remember it was
was
um
cisco he was working for cisco at the
time
and he said you know i just got
remarried and i've taken on a bunch of
step kids i'm not making enough money
and i'm thinking what i got to do is go
out and get my pmp
you know do you have a class that you're
teaching that i can come to and i said
yes and to make a long story short he
came to my class he passed the exam the
first time
and then he did something that's
brilliant which is what we're talking
about today
is he actually promoted himself
and how now being certified he could
serve his company better than he could
before
and his idea was is if i'd handled this
properly i should be able to get a raise
and with that raise i can be able to
better support my new bigger family
so after he got his credential he did a
little bit of self-promotion
and he sent some emails out to you know
some strategically selected people in
his company
and in two weeks
he was promoted and got a significant
raise now nothing really changed in his
life and his skill sets
really except that he now had this
credential that he could say
look what i've done and look what i am
now
you know having been certified you know
capable of doing it and it's not like he
wasn't
incapable before you get the credentials
are this designation that
means something in the the world but it
doesn't always reflect the reality of a
person becoming better skilled now if
you're on this webinar i expect that
you're already doing
project management stuff and you
probably already have some skills but
you're trying to figure out how you can
fast track your career a bit
so what i wanted to do is just focus
kind of briefly on 10 things
that you can do to
market your project and i guess in a way
it's really marketing yourself if you
will most project managers unless you're
doing an entrepreneurial project really
don't have a project to market
although in some large organizations
project managers
do select and promote their own projects
but in either
scenario here whether it's your own
thing or whether it's something within
an organization
being able to intelligently and
persuasively talk about aspects of your
project
is going to be critical
for example number one is
the ability to develop a persuasive
charter or vision for your project
now
um in the waterfall world we typically
refer to the word charter
as the you know founding core document
for the project in agile we refer to it
as a vision some people still call it a
charter but essentially what the charter
does is authorizes the existence of a
project
and the project manager to actually
apply organizational resources to the
various project activities
now
when you go through our trainings
to be certified like either for pmp or
acp or asm
in fact you know
if i were hiring somebody i'd want to
see somebody that had all three of those
now that may not be something you can do
you know in a month or two but you could
probably get yourself on track to get
something like that done in about six
months and then i could tell you if you
sent me a resume i think okay this
person knows his stuff and that's the
kind of person i want
but let's uh
focus on what you would want to be able
to do with the charter to
you know kind of market yourself and
your project you want to be able to
come up with a charter that has a clear
description of its purpose or
justification
i'm not going to serve you well if
you can't have clarity
and that clarity is going to require
having identified high level
requirements
high level risks
a summary budget a summary schedule
and what the success criteria looks like
now can you picture yourself
talking to
a senior manager and being able to
explain this and talk either about a
future project or a current project
touching on these things
you're going to impress the heck out of
somebody
okay so now let's talk about another
thing here explain how integrating with
operations is going to result in a
faster return on investment
now particularly when it comes to the
agile approach
being able to align projects with
operations in a way that will allow
completed work to be integrated even
before the project is finished
becomes a huge advantage
and what i did is i actually just stole
a slide from one of our trainings to
just give you an idea of how we talk
about aligning
the results of a project with operations
and you can see here without getting
into the details that at the very bottom
in that blue bar you can see what
operations is concerned with and then
above that you can see the various
aspects of an agile project and how
being aligned with operations is going
to make sure that operations
ends up with what it needs as soon as
it's possible to accomplish that
so again picture yourself being able to
communicate this concept effectively
with senior management or a customer
potential customer
and when you go through the trainings
and get certified you know we go over
all of this stuff so that you have the
ability to actually
communicate that
um third one that
i identified is to
explore the feasibility of the project
to actually be able to address
the issues of whether the project can
actually be done
now the project manager
is a key subject matter expert when it
comes to feasibility
a project manager doesn't necessarily
have to be a shmee when it comes to the
actual work of the project
but does need to be a subject matter
expert when it comes to actually
managing projects
and so a good project manager is going
to be able to talk intelligently about
things like what if scenario analysis if
we do this as opposed to that these are
the kind of results that we'll be
looking at if we do this as opposed to
that here are the different kinds of
risks that we might encounter
alternatives analysis we can approach it
this way we can approach it another way
the advantages of this way are these the
advantages of going the other way or
another way are these
also there may be some constraints that
are a factor for the project and being
able to intelligently
address
estimating your cost your schedule the
necessary resources and the effort
involved
is going to be a factor in
exploring the feasibility of a project
design of experiments that's a tool that
is used
early in projects to determine exactly
what it is the project should actually
build or how it should go about building
it
so talking about that kind of stuff you
can see how if you know if you can
picture in your mind being able to
intelligently address these things how
you are going to rise in the eyes of
those that are looking for
skilled and capable people to run
projects in an organization
the fourth thing that i identified is
effectively developing and securing
scope approval
now the scope of a project
is
the
sort of like the overall
amount of work that needs to be done as
well as what it is that actually needs
to be built so a good scope statement
for example actually has two parts it's
a
description of what it is that's being
built for the project
and another description of the work
that's involved for it
so
a good project manager is going to
understand how to go out and collect the
requirements from the key stakeholders
and make sure that there is clarity
and
a meeting of the mind so that when the
project is over
you know the key stakeholders say that's
not what i meant
so collecting the requirements and then
being able to develop a scope statement
that covers both the product scope and
the project scope so the product is the
actual results of the project the
project scope is the work that's
involved in creating it
helps accomplish that meeting of the
mind so that when the project is
actually concluded
everybody says yes that is exactly what
i wanted
now once you have um
scope
that is clear and approved then
understanding how to take that scope and
break it down into manageable pieces
we actually call that creating a work
breakdown structure
and you know here's a simple example of
a work breakdown structure and of course
depending on what kind of project it is
that you're marketing or addressing you
know something like this
could be adequate or something much more
complex
you know for example one time i did a
project management training for a u.s
missile defense contractor
and they showed me their wbs for one of
their missile projects
and it actually spanned about a 30 foot
wall with thousands of items on it
now
as a project manager who's marketing a
project you don't have to know all of
the details of all of those thousands of
items but if you can convey to
senior management or the customer that
look once we have a meeting of the minds
on the scope
this is what we're going to do and we're
going to chunk down the scope into these
manageable pieces until we can
intelligently figure out how much how
long what's needed for each of these
little components
and then you'll be able to demonstrate
that yeah we can get this whole project
done
no matter how complex it is or how long
it's going to take
and all of these things of course we
cover in our various
certification exam prep classes
five demonstrate how you will
effectively lead the team
you know
as project management emerged as a
profession
there was
a whole group of project managers that
were getting certified that were
brilliant when it came to tools and
techniques
but they did not know how to run teams
you would put them in front of a team
and they didn't know how to lead a team
so if you want to be a good project
manager you're also going to have to be
able to
learn leadership skills and the dynamics
of teams one of the things that we cover
in our various trainings is the
um
five stages of team development forming
storming norming performing and
adjourning and we talk about each of
those stages
imagine if you were to be able to
explain to senior management or a
customer you know here's what it's going
to look like here are the steps that the
team's going to go through as we
assemble the team and work on the
project and eventually close it
also acquiring leadership skills
you know i used to think that good
leaders were born
i don't think that anymore what i have
discovered is that there are actually
skills tools and techniques that leaders
use
and they can be learned these are not
hard you know
inbred things that you're born with
these are soft skills that can be
practiced learned and you can become
excellent at and we cover those kinds of
things
a good leader for example knows how to
create a vision
you know here's what we're going to do
here's what the customer is going to get
out of it here's what you're going to
get out of we're going to do something
amazing it's never been done before and
all these people are going to be
benefited in this way so you create this
vision so that people want to be a part
of the project and they want to
have you lead it
influencing
influencing is one of the soft skills
that leaders have influencing is where
you
catalyze a change
without demanding without being
dictatorial
um
great leaders
are able to
influence
what others do
without demanding it from them without
forcing them to do it
you'll get much more done when people of
their own choice decide to do what you
need to get done as opposed to
compelling them so we talk about that
for example we also talk about effective
decision making and we get into conflict
management the various aspects of
participatory decision making you know
like consensus majority plurality
dictatorship flip a coin we go into all
that kind of stuff
number six is demonstrate how you will
address project uncertainty so you know
what uncertainty is risk
we often think about risk as being a
negative thing but it's really not risk
is just uncertainty so you can have
things that
occur
that are going to
be an opportunity for your project that
would be positive risk or be a threat
that would be
negative risk
and one of the things that we'll go over
is
probability and impact matrices
imagine being able to intelligently sit
down with the key stakeholder and say
look at what we've come up for our
project and you know we've got some
opportunities
we've got some
threats and then be able to
talk about how you're going to address
the threats and we talk about the tools
and techniques like you see here but you
could also talk about how to address
opportunities and we have the tools and
techniques here that you use to address
positive risks
in all of the the trainings that i have
done and as i've seen project managers
grow and be able to more effectively run
projects and promote themselves in their
projects
one of the most important things is this
whole risk thing
if you
understand risk and you understand how
to identify it
and what to do
for threats and opportunities you become
so empowered because you're no longer
afraid of risk you know what to do about
it
and you can handle it and you can
effectively address it
um
one of the biggest
failure causes causes a failure that i
see in the real world
are
projects where the leadership in the
project the project manager does not
know how to deal with risk so we get
into this of course but imagine
being able to by talking about these
things and others that we cover in our
trainings
with senior management so that they get
this feeling like wow you know what
this person can really handle this
project they know what to do
number seven is demonstrate how to
develop an accurate and measurable
budget
now there's different ways to do this
depending on whether you're doing
waterfall or agile and so depending on
the training
that you're taking we'll cover how to do
that this chart right here actually is a
um
budget for um and cost baseline for a
waterfall project
and you can see that it's got um
funding requirements got a baseline it
can be used to track actual expenditures
so that you can measure your actuals
against the baseline and know whether or
not
you're on target
agile's done a little bit differently so
when we're training on those we'll talk
about how you deal with
um budgets when it comes to agile
projects but
you know
whether it's an external customer or
internal like you know senior management
um being able to intelligently talk
about how you're going to develop a
budget and how you're going to measure
the budget is probably one of the things
that they will be most focused on right
everybody's worried about the bottom
line and what do what does senior
management worry about most
whether or not you are
going to
finish the project on budget
or on time right it's always about cost
and time
and so we also will talk about how you
come up with an accurate schedule and
how you're going to measure it
here's an example of
a
schedule um using some of the more
modern tools that we have now unlike
things that we had in the past
and you can see that it's broke it's
taken a wbs essentially broken it down
into components and then you can see the
various um linkages between the tasks
and we get into all of that predecessors
successors you know finish to start
start to finish etc
and you know being able to use those
words and
share the different alternative
sequences etc with senior management and
potential customers is going to
just make them do flips they'll be so
happy because they're going to say okay
i'm talking to somebody that gets that
i need the project to come in on budget
and on time and this individual knows
how to get that done
you know chip mentioned managing
expectations of key stakeholders
probably the single most important thing
any successful project manager does
is develop a working relationship with
key stakeholders and then effectively
manages their expectations
and
you could return a project that is
perfect in its scope it came in right on
budget right on schedule but if you had
a bad working relationship with this key
stakeholders they're not even going to
be happy they're not going to care
um
often when it comes to projects just
like in life
it is more important how people feel
around you
than what you actually do now obviously
you have to perform right you have to
deliver the project
but
the ability to identify stakeholder
needs
manage their expectations
be able to recruit their participation
as appropriate and as needed is going to
be perhaps one of the greatest keys to
success that
you'll have as a project manager
and then the last thing i wanted to talk
about here is just um
being able to
oh i kind of skipped over this didn't i
when it comes to managing expectations
you know i just
picked out a couple of things here
there's the power interest grid
identifying where they are on the grid
and then how you're going to engage with
them
also interpersonal skills is a factor
here you know building trust resolving
conflict active listening
um overcoming resistance to change as
well as managerial skills being able to
facilitate consensus influence people we
chatted about that negotiate
and even modify organizational behavior
and then the last thing that i wanted to
bring your attention to is just
the importance of being able to
successfully close out a project
any project is going to require what we
call
verification
verification is
like if you're explaining this to
someone that doesn't you know understand
project management you would say
verification is
proving that you did it correctly
right if you've got a door that you're
building
um you would do quality control to prove
that the door
worked correctly the door handles work
the hinges were strong enough when it
was closed it was a tight seal or you
know whatever it is you did it correctly
but that's only part of successfully
closing a project
the other part
is called validation
validation is all about customer
acceptance
so
we
verified that we did the door correctly
then we demonstrate it for the customer
so the customer can say
yes that is what i wanted you did what
you were supposed to do
so
verification is
correctness and validation
is completeness and acceptance
and if you can demonstrate that for the
various components of your project as
well as for the overall project you did
it you got it done now there's some
other things you know i started out by
telling you this story about my friend
um
my friend paul
i told you he got a raise after he got
certified
and we're talking about a two-week span
right not much changed in his life at
work in two weeks except that he got a
credential
and there are studies out there that are
conducted routinely by organizations
like pmi and others where they look at
what project managers earn and compare
the delta between those that are
certified and those that are not
and it varies from year to year but it
is between 15 and 20 percent difference
if you have credentials you're going to
make more money than your non-certified
peers now you're going to have to do a
little bit of marketing and promotion
like we've been talking about
there's a language that's associated
with project management you'll learn the
words you'll learn about the tools and
techniques and you will be able to
promote yourself just like my buddy did
if he had never sent those emails and
engaged with senior management the way
he did
nobody would have known but he kind of
owned his career and he was able to use
the credentials that he got in order to
fast track it
so
think about you know what organizations
are really looking for
they want to know
that you can
expertly deliver a project on scope
on time
and on budget
they also want to know
how you're going to align your project
with it service management
i guess this is more narrowly focused on
software projects but if you're dealing
with software this is going to be a
piece
um and in fact good project managers in
my opinion are going to get their
waterfall and agile credentials then
they're probably going to get into itil
you know and
get some kind maybe an itil foundation
certification
and then the third bullet there has to
do with continuous improvement and
quality and you know they're going to be
looking for folks that understand six
sigma
and know how within a project
they can
successfully lead improvement efforts
continuous improvement
on
improving the product as well as the
project itself
now um i think chip's probably going to
talk about this
a little bit more but if not let me just
touch on it quickly um at simply learn
we have what we call our
pm expert masters program where we
group different credentials together
into packages that make it affordable
and
sequenced in a way that's going to help
you
accomplish this effort to acquire the
credentials that you need in order to
be the go-to project manager in your
organization
um when you get involved with us in any
kind of a learning endeavor we have um a
an lms a learning management system that
is second to none
with tests you know mock tests
content
tips and tricks on how to pass tests etc
we also have a community that we call
simply talk where you can engage with
instructors you can engage with other
students you can i get ideas on how to
pass exams
where to find jobs all kinds of stuff
like that
and with that chip maybe i should just
pass it back to you so that you can deal
with any questions that have come up or
clarify any things that maybe i wasn't
as clear as i could have been on
sure thing uh you were extraordinarily
clear though really nicely organized
presentation very much appreciate that
and you're getting some very positive
feedback in the questions here
along with a few questions some some
thank yous for the presentation
so we'll we'll go loop through the
questions here in just a moment the
first thing i'm going to do though i'm
going to ask everybody to
to indulge me for just a moment while i
take over the screen
i got to find my correct
here we go
so this takes over the screen
and the reason i do that is because you
know this is a public-facing webinar
right so that means that anybody can
join us today and we're happy that you
did we've got lots and lots of people
from all around the globe uh but you may
uh or may not be familiar with what
simply learn is all about beyond these
webinars and jeff did a great job of
explaining uh some of the courses that
are available and the packages that are
available you mentioned the lms
our learning management system which is
really quite a remarkable environment to
be taking your training in
and the community that's there so
there's much more to simply learn than
this series of webinars that we offer
throughout the month
uh the the core uh service that we offer
is in fact as a business and technology
training provider we have more than 400
web-based training courses across a wide
spectrum of skill sets so not just
project management and it's related uh
skills but
lots and lots of things from digital
marketing to
project management data science software
and application development all sorts of
things
and all of these courses are designed
pardon me and
to address
the
requirements of third-party certified
certifying organizations like prince2
pmi omcp in the open group and excellent
and so on so these trainings are
designed to help
specifically prepare you for these uh
training uh sorry for these
certifications
and uh and are specifically designed to
meet their most recent uh books of
knowledge all these courses are designed
by our faculty of course of experienced
professional trainers like jeff and you
get all of these structured courses the
information the resources the hands-on
projects and simulation exams as he
mentioned and so forth so
if you are interested
in learning more about uh what we can
help you with with regard to your
specific training to prepare you for a
specific certification if you tick the
right box we'll have somebody get in
touch with you and they can give you a
walkthrough of the
learning platform they can talk to you
about what your goals are for your
career for your business help you choose
the right course to meet your goals
and so on so no obligation but a great
way to get that that backstage pass
the other thing i would mention there's
no place here on this thing of course
for you to put in a phone number but if
you want to fast track and have somebody
call you as opposed to email you back
feel free to drop your phone number into
the question module nobody else is going
to be able to see it but we'll have it
on record there it'll be attached to
your uh to your information and that way
we'll give you a call
and get somebody on the phone with you
uh and if of course if you don't want to
do that no problem i will get a hold of
you via email
so all right i think i've taken over the
screen for long enough let me close that
and we should go back to seeing uh
jeff's screen here in just a moment
i'm hoping i'm waiting for go to webinar
to catch up with me there we go
all right so just so you know we are
seeing your screen sir
uh we have a number of questions here um
i will tackle the first and most common
question which is uh is this being
recorded will be able to see the
recording uh can we download the slide
deck etc and the answer is uh yes we are
recording this webinar uh we record all
of our webinars it will be cleaned up
and produced and the recording made
available uh on the simply learn site as
well as probably on our youtube channel
if you're already a member of uh simply
learn of course you'll see it pop up
there at the site
but we do have your information here and
we'll be reaching out to folks that
joined us for this webinar and letting
you know the status of that and lastly
if you have not already subscribed to
our youtube channel you should probably
go ahead and do that because uh if this
does make it up there or any of the
other awesome new videos that get posted
there and added to our channel you'll
get a notification if you are a
subscriber
all right
the very uh first question we got uh
from hanuma uh asked if it's possible
for you to go
back and just show us again the slide
that was right before project charter so
i know that's
a little ways back there but
i think that there was some good
information there that onoma was hoping
to be able to revisit i don't think we
had a specific question but if it's up
on the screen for a moment that might
help
and
let's see let me click through my
questions here
and
there we go i hope that's helpful hanuma
um
ranjit is asking uh if you might speak
briefly to prince2
uh with regard to project management uh
as
opposed to pmp and what the difference
there might be and why one might do one
over the other
i can
so prince2 and pmp are the two most
common
waterfall credentials
they are
similar
and if you were in a position where you
needed to decide whether to go the
prince2 route or the pmp route
what i would recommend doing is looking
at where you want to go with your career
for example if you were going to be
working in um
you know great britain for example
probably prince2 is going to be better
if you're going to be working in the u.s
or for u.s based companies
pmp is going to be the best choice
um if you're thinking more about the
middle east in europe it's a little bit
of a toss-up you would want to take a
look at the companies that you have an
interest in working for
and discovering which
approach they favor
now to bring it back to a more general
concept is if you want to be a good
project manager going forward you need
to have either the pmp or the prince too
i'm us-based you know my world is much
more pmp centric than it is prince2
um
but that's you know because of where i
am um i know people who favor prince too
and so that's probably something that
you will be best served by exploring on
your own but remembering that
uh both of them are waterfall or
traditional project management
approaches
absolutely helped me
and i suspect it helped
the person who asked as well i'm sorry i
already deleted the question so i can't
say your name but i hope that that
helped
um
another comment here just in general
saying thank you so much for this
presentation i'm learning so much more
than i expected
um
all right we have a another question
here is it possible are these separate
certifications pmp agile and waterfall
or uh is agilent waterfall a uh
an approach that's wrapped up in the pmp
certification
they are separate so let's be just a
little bit clearer on the potential
credentials that would be worth
considering
when it comes to waterfall either pmp
or
prince2
when it comes to agile
either pmi acp or asm
both would actually be good they both
have some emphases that the other one
doesn't have but those are two key agile
certifications and you need at least one
of them so for example you could do the
pmp and the asm
and you would have two credentials that
would demonstrate that you are
a versatile project manager and could
handle a more traditional project you
know like looking at the chart on the
screen right now the the simple or the
complicated boxes
as well as an agile approach
and here's the other thing team is that
if you have
both of those kinds of certifications
you will find that
you will actually
run an agile project better
because you've got a waterfall
background as well and vice versa you
will actually be more effective in a
waterfall project with your agile
background so i think that you know as
projects go forward the reality of it is
is that most projects become a bit of a
hybrid
project that will have elements of both
agile and waterfall
perfect question
i i believe so yes and we have a
follow-up question from the same person
as a certified project management
professional what if you don't know how
to use project management software like
for instance microsoft project or any
others that are required
does that have a negative effect as a
certified pm and i imagine that you're
going to get some familiarity with these
tools
during the course yes
um you get exposure to tools and
techniques but we don't drill down on
how to use them
so
um it's a great question because you
know credentials set you up for success
and they will fast hack your career
but you are going to want to figure out
how to use some of the tools and
techniques and again understanding who
you're working for and what they favor
is going to be perhaps the single most
important input in deciding what other
things you might want to do for example
you know if you're working for a company
that says we use microsoft project for
managing our projects you better learn
how to use microsoft project and we can
help you with that as well
but the certification
courses that we take don't get deeply
into actual possible tools
like microsoft project or competitors
that they exist how we use them that's
covered but not specifically how to
actually use the software themselves
there are
training courses available though for
folks if they want to get right into the
specific tools and and it might also
be relevant to this other question
coming in from pawan which is
uh do you know of any organizations or
would you recommend seeking out
organizations where you can join as a
voluntary consultant that might give one
some experience hands-on with some tools
in a in an environment uh where they're
still sort of honing the skill sets is
that recommended
yeah
um
and i'm thinking here
you know one of the things that's helped
me the most
in kind of networking and discovering
resources and connections like you're
asking about is actually joining pmi now
again that's sort of the pmp approach
so you know like i said that's my
background but in most areas there's a
monthly chapter meeting for pmi
where you can volunteer you can get
involved in training programs you can
get involved as being a trainer
um
so a huge advantage if you're going to
be a project manager particularly if
you're going the pmi route is actually
to join pmi and participate in your
local chapter
uh great advice yeah i understand that
the community there is really uh really
uh deep and uh
very supportive
um let's see we got a bunch of questions
here i want to make sure we manage to
blast through as many as we can
and i know that these are specific to
the course so we should be able to
answer these quickly how long does it
take to prepare for the certification so
if i was going to take for a pmp
certification
if
magelin was going to
take a course to prep for the cert
how long would we imagine that might
take
i hate that question how long
it depends actually i get the question
and
um
my approach isn't
to answer how long it's to focus in on
how to know when you're ready so let me
address it that way um if you take our
certification course we're going to
cover everything that's going to be on
the test well i should back up we're
going to cover enough that's on the test
so that you can pass the test you will
get questions on the certification exam
you don't know the answer to it's just
not possible unless you're taking you
know six months of in-depth study to
actually be prepared to answer any
potential question on the test but
that's not our objective our objective
is to get the credential and that we're
great at
and what we do is provide you with a
number of practice exams
and your performance on the practice
exams is what's going to determine when
you're ready to sit for the real exam so
for example let's say that
if you did a live training our pmp
course is four days long if you do one
of our virtual classes
during the week it's going to be 10
work days long but at the end of the
class
you could take one of our practice exams
and if you got 80 or better i would say
go take the exam you're ready if you
didn't quite get to the 80 percent you
got to do a little bit more work a
little bit more study a little bit more
practice but as soon as you can get to
that 80 percent or higher uh level on
our practice tests then you know you're
ready to go past the real exam
so that could happen the day you end the
training with us or maybe it takes you
know a couple weeks afterwards and then
of course there are other variables that
you know would be unique to your own
circumstances like how much time can you
devote each day
are you willing to
memorize some of the things i recommend
in our tips and tricks videos and things
like that so
um how long is largely a function of you
so
uh what your circumstances are like so i
would say on the short end a week on the
long end you know five or six weeks very
good and totally reasonable uh we all
have a lot of uh things that we're
juggling in our lives so as much time as
we have to put into training uh you know
that's how quickly we'll move through it
carlos is asking if this training would
count as pdus towards those uh for those
who are already certified
yes
short and simple answer yes carlos
it will count as your pd is
good to know uh let's see
quite a few questions here and i love
that everybody's asking so many
questions i want to get through uh a few
more what time do we have here actually
i'm not oh boy we're almost right up
against it here um i've heard of scrum
says sriram is uh that the same as pmi
acp or are they
different
so scrum is
one of the
methods that belong to the agile family
of project management
there are others like extreme
programming and kanban and
lean kanban and crystal and others scrum
is the single most popular agile
method for doing projects
acp
covers scrum
most in depth but then also covers
others
which is actually a huge advantage if
you're only going to be doing scrum
because
scrum actually borrows concepts tools
and techniques
from many of the other agile methods
so to be a really good scrum
practitioner
exposure to an understanding of other
key agile methods is critical
the asm certification
i know your question was about acp but
the asm
is uh focuses on scrum but also includes
um a little bit about the other methods
as well so that
either the acp or the asm both become
pretty viable credentials um along with
your waterfall credential
and asm stands for
agile scrum master agile scrum master
there you go so that answers another
question that had come up for suganthon
too perfect
we dovetailed right into that uh let's
see if we can get a couple of more
carlos is asking what is the webinar
code
i'm not sure quite what you mean but if
you reference today's date and the topic
of the webinar uh then by all means uh
you can do oh the webinar id number if
that's what you're looking for carlos
real quickly i'm going to give this to
you because you want to keep track of
this is one eight five five seven two
one seven one that's the webinar id oh
oh oh to report it to uh pmi so uh
carlos is asking if if attending this
webinar
counts towards uh
pdus
oh you know what that's a good question
it's not going to be on one of the
pre-registered courses that you
automatically get some pdus
um but i would claim it
um you know pmi could you know could say
no but if you
share what was covered
um you know a key a couple key things um
pmi will probably accept it
let me also just grab real quick here
this is the the link i'm going to put
this into the chat module for everybody
to see
this is the link to this particular
webinar which i believe even after the
webinar is over this link stays live
and visible it'll just say that this
event has passed uh but if it's helpful
maybe you can uh
point them towards that url
all right uh let's see if we can squeeze
in one more um
something
in the questions here uh uh
that we could answer quickly so many
great questions
um
from the top 10 tricks that you showed
which one do you think should be used
when stakeholders seem to be the ones
jeopardizing the project because of
their own inherent difficulty
oh my gosh how much time do we have i
guess i didn't choose an easy question
sorry about that
just give us a number one or ten
yeah um
well of this list right here
of course um number nine is the one that
we would focus on
and you know number nine if i can get
right
back to it
um is really
about how to
identify who your stakeholders are
and learn what their interests in the
project are and then
crafting your engagement strategy with
the stakeholders and it can differ from
stakeholder to stakeholder and but you
can also see that there are a number of
soft skills so once you kind of classify
your stakeholders then having
interpersonal skills and managerial
skills that you can bring to the table
to be effective in your engagement
that's where that's what you want to do
what you want to work on
makes perfect sense
uh i wish we had time to get to every
single question and i'm so happy that
people were so uh you know engaged and
i'm sorry that we
we can't get to everybody i do want to
let you all know that i just shared some
links into the chat box so take a look
at that i've got you uh some links there
to upcoming webinars to simply learn
courses on project management
a listing called what we call career
edge which allows you to sort of dig
around among all the resources across
all of the specialties not just project
management but all the various
specialties that we cover so you'll see
white papers and articles and case
studies and upcoming webinars and all
kinds of fun things in there i gave you
a link to pmi.org too
so take a look at that click through get
those open in your browser real quick
before we shut down here for the day
so you've got them to refer to after
we're all done talking uh one more time
i want to say that we're getting some
wonderful feedback for you sir
nice simple language method of
explanation uh got a lot of the answers
that i was looking for says another
person um
uh they have some experience all now
that they feel uh confident in moving
forward uh in a short time so
thank you sir for sharing your wisdom
with us here today it was fun to hang
out with you here again
my pleasure chip you do a great job at
this and team i wish you the best i want
you to not just be successful project
managers but i want your lives enhanced
and i just you know success to you at
work and at home and whatever you do
absolutely absolutely uh and with that
said please do join us on future
webinars folks go ahead and click
through to the upcoming webinars page
find whatever is of interest to you we
would love to have you back with us uh
and until then have a terrific rest of
your day everybody or your afternoon or
your evening and we will see you here
the next time we do this thanks so much
bye
you